hey what's up guys it's your boy Ty
Dollar Sign make sure you check me out
on the bootleg Kev podcast
it is the bootleg cab show
we have a special guest
he brought his cancer sticks to the
interview we're smoking cigarettes this
is not marijuana don't do all that bad
we got Ty dollar sign here how you doing
my brother I'm good man it's good to see
you good to see you too man it's been
awesome I mean I see I've seen you
around but I feel like I just saw you at
the Joyner Show backstage that's okay
okay okay yeah that's right yeah yeah I
must have been smoking something else
must have been smoking something else
but it's good to see you man loving this
new record I appreciate it you mustard
and Dirk shout out to my brothers
um it's been a minute since we dropped
and uh we back back like we never left
it is interesting that like you guys are
doing a joint album together which feels
like overdue
I can uh I could see that it feels like
you know there should have been like
this like I don't know seven years ago
or something but maybe yeah but we're
doing it now you know like what it could
have doesn't matter it doesn't matter
you know the record is here the record
is here is one of the greatest records
that you're gonna hear and uh
I can't wait for you to hear man I was
gonna say timing wise like why was it
like you know what Now's the Time like
let's do it let's get together let's do
a whole [ __ ] album you know God's
Thomas
that's why yeah that's why you know
God's time you want God's timing I'm an
atheist so I don't know but you know
guys tell me whether you want to believe
it or not yeah hello hello how many
records
uh enough just the perfect amount not
one of those albums that have all these
records for streams trying to cheat you
know I'm saying you either Gonna Love it
or you're not so it's one of them ones
you'll see like God there's 27 something
yeah cheating y'all cheating make an
actual good album yeah how about no
filler all bangers let's go body of work
let's go yeah oh man that's what I'm
talking about you're one of the I do
feel like when it comes to bodies of
work though you're one of the most
consistent artists at least in my
opinion when I know if you drop a
project it would even go to the mixtape
days like I just know that there's I
could just press play that means a lot
my brother I appreciate it yeah even the
last album uh there was like
there was like some stuff that I feel
like uh when the album came out it was
amazing but there were so many records
that didn't make that last project yeah
that you had played me yeah that's a
whole nother yeah we ended up making a
whole nother album last minute
just because I was having fun in the
studio and that's the one I decided to
go with and the division album was dope
thank you I appreciate that as well
shout out to my brother Daniel shout out
to uh 85 I just seen him out in Miami
they got a new album that's about the
job I think yeah it comes out next week
I think oh that's gonna be crazy
don't never want to send the album early
I don't know what's up with that but
send that thing I love how they got in
with JD and like I'm like I'm hearing
these songs and I'm like this [ __ ]
reminds me of like 99 r b which is a
good thing by the way yeah I mean that's
what I feel like R B has been missing
everybody got lazy with it so when you
get artists like division you know going
crazy brim fires going crazy
uh myself of course
it's a couple week a name for sure is
doing it but you know that's a good
thing for sure 100 shout out to JD 100
shot JD uh for you though what has been
like was there any sort of like
creative difference for you honing in
with one producer for a whole project or
was it kind of did it make it easier was
it more difficult was it did it change
your process at all
when I'm working with mustard it's like
my you know he's my brother you know I'm
saying we started in this [ __ ] together
so it's like working with if it was me
and you working on some [ __ ] you guys
are like on magazine covers and [ __ ]
together you guys are very synonymous
with each other so it was it was easy
it was easy man just his ideas my ideas
back and forth back and forth it was
quick you know
the actual time we spent in the studio
how long did it like if you had a guess
estimate like how long did it take for
you to know it didn't take more than a
month to knock it out but just spend
over time due to his schedule and my
schedule wow do you get first like dibs
over the beats
for sure
he gave me all this fire [ __ ] and then I
was giving him you know ideas Melodies
with vocals and then he'll add his parts
to it and we're just going back and
forth like that so it was crazy yeah I
was whenever I'm talking about you in
interviews I always say that creatively
you're a genius I appreciate it man
you're historically one of the more
slept on artists somehow of our time I
don't like that slept on [ __ ] I'm one of
the greatest artists of our time so
y'all got to stop saying that [ __ ]
you're a genius stop pushing that
narrative Ty Dolla Sign one of the best
y'all ever heard I agree fully
um are we are we oh we're going chain
we're chaining them hey let me just hold
one can I hold one can you light one and
just let me hold it
let me just soak up some of that [ __ ]
cans you know what I mean
for people who don't know you're not
like a regular smoker but these are
special these are special I don't know
why I'm going so fast on them right now
I got a ration these things out I'm
gonna just take one pool just to keep it
lit
that's the first time I've ever smoked a
cigarette actually when I was eight did
you you gotta bite that first one a
little Tangy part
no you gonna hear it
look at it you see the little orange
part that's not I'm not comfortable with
anymore all right here you go yeah
wait wait when did Dwight get here what
the [ __ ] I got both we got both Atlantic
reps in this [ __ ] oh man it's
special man we out here come on do you
bringing them out I'm going number one
you're bringing them out
um yeah shout out to dark man uh I love
the the new record obviously uh I feel
like you're the kind of artist that when
you get in with somebody that there
might be like five or six unreleased
songs with them sitting on a hard drive
somewhere
yeah is that is that a fair assumption
in general with Ty yeah you know off and
on uh Dirk especially with me and bro
like we was on the uh
covered a double XL freshman together
and been doing this since then and now
he's one of the biggest artists out
there you know so shout out to Dirk and
all the hard work he's put in and it's
you know I'm happy for bro for sure to
see all that [ __ ] pay off how many songs
unreleased do you have with him I mean I
couldn't even say it but we got songs
for sure
it's crazy because I kind of uh I even
just just back to the Chicago thing uh
obviously Dirks
at OG like we've seen him grow into this
Superstar over the last 10 years first
time I ever saw a guy like little Bibby
baby was on tour with you yeah was it
was that [ __ ] what was that like 2014
and now he's obviously a huge executive
and he's richer than everybody you know
yeah wow he did his thing you know what
I'm saying it's a it's good to see [ __ ]
like that but you're always pretty much
all work pays off I was gonna say you
were pretty much tapped in with Chicago
like from the rib yeah yeah shout out to
all my brothers out there you know rest
in peace Fredo rest in peace Alfredo
indeed uh speaking of Chicago
your friend Kanye man you guys have
Classics together yes uh
uh I he's my favorite artist of all time
he's up there all his albums are up
there you see the little bears yes sir
have you spoken with also one of the
greatest artists of our time have you
spoken with him that's the Ty Dolla Sign
any of this craziness has been going on
I have not got a chance to speak to him
now
um I feel like you guys are genuine
friends is that safe to assume yeah for
sure one bro
um you know I feel like
Kanye at times says things that
probably
I feel like the bigger Point gets lost
in some of the delivery that he'd be
saying
um would you what would like would you
say based on some of the narratives that
are being painted about yay with some of
the some of the anti-semitic [ __ ] I feel
like you know him better than most of
the people that are speaking about him
I would say he's a great guy I would say
he does what he wants
there's got to be something that he's
you know trying to get across for
whatever he's doing and at the end of
the day he's a great guy so we love
Kanye and you guys have Classics
together yeah for sure 100 when you work
with uh because you've you work with a
guy like muster who again a modern day
Legend yeah one of the best producers of
Our Generation you've worked with the a
what's the creative difference between
those two guys in the studio
the individuals uh yay has the way he
does [ __ ] much has the way he does [ __ ]
it's completely different but
I mean you can hear it I just mean like
in terms of like the process because I
always hear yay is like more sporadic
like sometimes he just might set up a
[ __ ] microphone in the corner over
there and like but most of them may do
the same thing so it's just different
styles you know we came up different
ways and have different techniques of
doing this [ __ ] but at the end of the
day we all make bangers so but way
different
there's just a different route to
getting to the Banger with each person
right yeah has there been a producer
because you know a lot of people don't
know this about you you're kind of like
a what I would consider to be a quite
the hip-hop head yeah for sure you love
you some J dilla yeah you know what I'm
saying uh there's been guys like Mad Lib
who've been pretty active recently like
putting out great records but like have
you got mad libs number I don't I don't
think anybody does that's that's one guy
I've been wanting to work with from the
beginning that I haven't got a chance to
I never really came across bro so I
don't think anyone's coming holler at me
bro if you hear this [ __ ] I was gonna
say that's somebody who you'd like to
work with I would love to work with Mad
Lib I recently just did an interview
with Talib kwali and we supposed to do
something he's also alleged to me and
someone always wanted to work with so
I love that type of music for show I
don't think people would put that like
together because I mean you've done some
records anybody that's a real time fan
with no like back from turning Corey
days all the way up to now and even like
if that that one-off I dropped with J
Cole like
if you hear that you would know that's
like that's my type of [ __ ] yeah Mad Lib
we got to make it happen
he's out there he's just he's making I
already made um all uh the uh [ __ ] uh
bandana [ __ ] the pretty good job I heard
he made that [ __ ] off his iPad
yeah man that's he a boy here you should
put this out too I'm just kind of
wasting it or you can just take it I
don't want it
you're just gonna waste my [ __ ] like
that man
that's some [ __ ] it just you know what I
understand the appeal of it though I
feel like I'm in a movie
I feel like we should be there should be
like green lights and pool tables around
yeah I feel you survived women you know
what I mean maybe some whiskey yeah but
I'm not trying to push push it on nobody
don't [ __ ] with it it's just trash
I just happen to like it yeah I respect
it hey whatever so uh you still a heavy
smoker on the on the on the ganja yeah
papers only still papers only still
still take the game to the day I die yes
you and Wiz are going to run it back on
the joint The Joint side what's up Wiz
let's do it yeah he got his new album
about to drop I'm on there for sure
what's it called G uh G was it what the
[ __ ] is it called he's not even on
Atlantic anymore you guys wouldn't even
[ __ ] know
Asylum
the exclusive the uh um deluxe edition I
think just dropped of Multiverse but
he's got his other [ __ ] G raw G Star G
song you know what
[ __ ] you got me erase this part God damn
it we could just pull it out and give
him a nice plug because because that's
our brother and we love him it's called
G something
uh
we gotta plug with his album man we
can't not do it yeah knowing him it's
probably nowhere on yeah there's no it's
got to be on his on his page I've been
seeing him
about it yeah he's been promoting it but
it's not in the captions oh g-rage she
rage she raids all right I race up until
here so the new Wiz album G rage man
that [ __ ] better go crazy crazy uh
um who's on the album man besides Dirk
on my album uh mustard and Ty dollar
sign and I'm featuring Ty Dolla Sign and
a lot of songs I mean of course you know
when you see that feature in Ty Dolla
Sign but when you see his own project
like he said you know that [ __ ] can't
ride not like these other albums
but who's on the album outside um
uh
mustard yeah you know what I'm saying
we've gathered that much 10 Summers easy
money you know
LMA
I mean if Ella Mae would bless us with a
verse
ad-lib you know
I'm not saying nothing yet man but you
know I'm a player for you pull up to the
studio after this yeah we've got a
studio right in there you just playing I
got you I got you I got you you can play
me some [ __ ] I got you yeah
the song's out we know Dirks are the
[ __ ] album man yeah get that my
friends man run that back shout out to
everybody playing that [ __ ] you heard it
first right here on bootleg cab
what did we hear first you gave me no
exclusives I gave you my friends y'all
heard it first oh I hear them what y'all
talking about this guy says Dwight gets
around he starts introducing [ __ ]
songs in the middle of the interview
um I'm just talking about the most
important song out right now man my
friends it's a great record Ty Dolla
signing mustard featuring a little dirt
you know what I'm saying we going up all
right we just charted on on something
today you know I'm saying that's our
first little rhythm right let's [ __ ]
go we're talking about
hey what up y'all bootleg cab got to
stop the interview to tell you about our
newest sponsor man shout out to the
homies at hardean Las Vegas that's right
the number one dispensary in the whole
state of Nevada let alone in the whole
[ __ ] country so many choices of
Premium cannabis ladies and gentlemen it
is like how can I put this you walk into
it you go to Jardine in Las Vegas
when you're on vacation when you're out
there tricking off whatever you're doing
stop off at hardean tell them I sense
you'll be like yo bootleg have sent me
they're gonna take care of you at
hardean when I say selection I mean
selection of the best premium cannabis
in the world the best dispensary there's
a reason why Jardine is world famous
follow them right now Harding underscore
Las Vegas go to their website
hardinglasvegas.com that's
j-a-r-d-i-n underscore Las Vegas when
you're in Vegas you have to pull up to
hardine tell them I sent you and get
high off your [ __ ] face I don't even
know what that means how do you get high
off of your face whatever melt your
[ __ ] face off with some of that good
hard Dean y'all go follow one more time
that's Hardy in underscore Las Vegas
let's get back to the interview
oh yeah I saw you with Malika Andrews uh
with the MPC on ESPN
what's up what happened there oh that
was amazing man we got a chance to uh
join the uh ESPN studio today me and
musty was making beats right there live
you know what I'm saying they ain't
really seen that but you know the tour
is coming soon you know you guys go on
tour you guys pull out the NPC that
before fmg
I remember I saw Jurassic 5 do that for
the first time when I was a kid uh cut
chemist and DJ Newmark pulled out the
[ __ ] NPC that [ __ ] blew my mind man
you and mustard did that together yeah
we did that today on ESPN it was
legendary yeah shout out to all my ESPN
fam and uh we got the
song as well we did a collab with the
NBA so basically every game you're gonna
hear it you know I'm saying like I said
the most important song right now I did
a remix the NBA version the ESPN version
you know I'm about to do the bootleg cat
version we out here are you gonna do
some uh some dead plates for the DJs of
course that's the most important you
know next to the fans shout out to all
my DJs out there it is man how have you
been uh besides recording relentlessly
uh you know I know you got to spend a
lot more time with the family during the
pandemic you know you obviously touring
and shows and [ __ ] yeah my daughter man
uh she started her clothing line and uh
the first drop is green eye girls
and uh she started her website she's 17
now she's playing basketball she's going
crazy
and you know just seeing that just
seeing her Blossom has just been one of
the greatest gifts from God for sure
she's a junior no she's a senior oh yeah
so my son's seven just turned 17 but
he's a junior it's kind of kind of crazy
having like a little adult in your
[ __ ] house right well how's it having
a young man is having a young lady I
mean listen I am scared to have a
daughter so if me and my wife have
another kid I'm kind of hoping I have a
daughter because I feel like it might
change me for the better yeah not to say
that I need a lot of changing I'm a
great [ __ ] catch you know what I'm
saying but my son my son is like a
little dude man like he's like a little
man like he's more mature than me yeah
which is a problem wow well he's
definitely like the one like yo Dad is
he a sniper
like with women is he a sniper Call of
Duty did he pour champagne on her
[Laughter]
girlfriend
that's what's up now he's got a
girlfriend she's a sweetheart this is
the but now he's like a you know he's
like a music nerd now oh for real yeah
like he used to be like you know into
like Fallout Boy and like Lil pump but
now he's like you know
diving in a vinyl and like it's dope to
see you know that's dope so he's like
leaning towards the DJ side the
production side
he shouldn't rap
don't do him like that nah him and his
friends be trying to rap and [ __ ] in
here like and it's [ __ ] terrible come
on man he might pop out the next few
months on some some young Mac Miller hey
maybe that'll be fired maybe man I don't
know uh hey yo take me back man to like
2012 2013 days All-Star days [ __ ]
tooting and booted days like at any
point in time did you foresee that you
and YG and mustard would be the face of
a generation of la music
did y'all even have like any sort of
like
I always dreamed since a kid even if you
go before that that
one day I would make my way
in you know into being that
um
when I first
met YG and I first met mustard
I would have never imagined you know I'm
saying that we was going to do what we
did just to be honest
but we did it for sure we teamed up and
it's been it's been a journey for sure
shout out to both of my brothers yeah
it's crazy because like I remember the
first time I ever met you
uh you guys are on tour with Bobby
Brackins and I think Ray Shawn wasn't
creation the video person on the tour
the Gucci Gucci chick wasn't she like
Bobby bracken's like camera she was the
camera she was the camera girl for sure
damn I forgot about that yeah she so was
man there's an interview of me with a
GoPro that is fuzzy as [ __ ] and you I'm
interviewing YG and Bobby Brackins
and I'm making fun of Bobby bracken's
pants and then you walk in and they're
like [ __ ] I was making fun of Bobby
Brookins exotic ass pants yeah
and you walk in and they're like oh this
is actually the guy that's on uh at the
like at the time like I I didn't know
who you were right so they were like oh
this is the guy who's actually up to the
boot or whatever and it was like it's
all on YouTube it's crazy I'm like yeah
the first time I met Ty's on YouTube
that's hard it's on YouTube I need that
I mean it's on the internet yeah so the
GoPro and that wasn't even a GoPro what
was the flip cam remember the flip cams
they had a little USB that popped out
yeah them shits were epic wow 100 do you
feel like um you've kind of uh caught
some
Tick Tock love during the pandemic like
a song like something new is obviously a
record that was a few years old but had
like a whole new life yeah on Tick Tock
but you don't make music for tick tock
you make Timeless records and if it
happens to work out that way great right
yeah do you feel like
now that the industry is changing and
like attention spans gotten short over
the last five years for sure but do you
feel like um
ever any frustration would just kind of
like you know wear like the music
industry's attention is like yo this has
to go on to I'm sure you hear from the
label I feel like that attention span
[ __ ] got shorter [ __ ] is like another
narrative and that's like
some [ __ ] to make it for people that
suck to be able to to make money on
music yes yeah like uh I'd rather just
make good ass music and like you said
wherever it goes It goes it happens it
happens but you're not like let's try to
make good music though instead of like
just making something for tick tock
making something to live for like five
seconds like let's make some Timeless
[ __ ] so yeah that's what I'm still on
and you've made timeless music your
whole career and like if we always look
at who's at the top
they are not doing they're not playing
along with no nothing Kendrick Lamar his
album is [ __ ]
every time it's like come on the new
[ __ ] is crazy every time every time for
sure who's got your favorite albums of
the year
Kendrick
Ty Dolla signing mustard okay you gotta
disqualify yourself it's not out yet
I know but I'ma just be honest is it
coming out this year
Ty Dolla Sign of mustard Kendrick Lamar
uh what else came out this year uh the
Freddy gives out on this great Triple S
uh I love jid's album
he goes crazy man I'm so proud of him
crazy Denzel Curry had a great album
this year Tana talk four from Benny was
great
um the Benny album was hard
it was great Finn Staples album I'll
listen to that [ __ ] a gang of time shout
out to Vince for sure Vince Staples
album is amazing who are we missing
there's been some good [ __ ] this year
though
yeah
he's still in it Simba was so offended
that I didn't have him in my list for
real yeah I mean it was it was a good
project
what Simba goes crazy and you're on his
first uh you know yeah
young boy I love it young boy everything
he'd been dropping I [ __ ] with his music
heavy every you've had enough time this
year to listen to everything I'll be
listening to his [ __ ] I [ __ ] with this
no I love his music too but I just don't
have time to listen to this
motherfucker's dropped 189 million songs
this year he got out of that Atlantic
deal in one year
he working he's going crazy Dwight's
like [ __ ] you
they just announced the Motown [ __ ] I
was just talking to Dwight what last
week mother said I'm [ __ ] with you
you heard an icy [ __ ] icy [ __ ] yeah that
sounds wild yeah so Rocky put me on his
music a minute ago that's a guy yeah I
see [ __ ] he from Chicago that's amazing
everything you dropped he'd be he doing
the Beats doing everything and then
[ __ ] hard as hell I like lucky Lucky's
dope yep Lucky's other two shots of
course uh
you already name uh bro but uh [ __ ] with
this [ __ ] a lot West Side you like eat
yeah I like eat shout out I like his
music you like the minion song
uh I think so it's really like
everything I just be playing the shits
through like the last two three albums
that's why I appreciate about you man
your [ __ ] taste is so vast yeah like
like you're the first person I've ever
heard play little Uzi in my life for
real we were in Boston and I did a show
like a we're in Lawrence uh
Massachusetts with DJ pup dog and
somehow we ended up in a hotel room
afterwards with I think Dre was there
and some strange people as well and uh
and yeah you were playing Uzi on
Soundcloud some strange people yo
another uh Larry June June of course The
Alchemist project hey shout out to
Alchemist man I want to see what's up
with you and Alchemist man how the [ __ ]
both of y'all from L.A yo Dre had his
number I text him from Dre's phone I
said hit me he ain't text me wow I don't
know
what's up Alchemist yeah Larry Jones
been on a tear my brother channeled
trust you heard him he makes like dance
music Funk just a really talented dude
so shout out to channel trust Thundercat
everything he's been dropping worse
um I gotta check out AC TWY that's my
favorite rap name ever yeah check him
out that's gonna [ __ ] with it I thought
that was for sure like icy [ __ ] sounds
like the illest like
if I was like a porn chick
I don't do him like that when you hear
the music I'm telling you okay I'm in
man
what up y'all we gotta stop the
interview real quick tell you about our
good friends at my bookie that's right
man my bookie is where you want to get
this money and uh enjoy uh being a
degenerate like myself and it's the best
time of the year to be a degenerate
because NFL season is uh obviously we
are in the midst of a crazy NFL season
NBA season just started World Series is
going down and you can get your bets in
right now go to my bookie and sign up
for a new account using the promo code
bootleg that's
b-o-o-t-l-e-g you sign up right now they
will match your first deposit that's
right put in a thousand oh they'll give
you another thousand to gamble with
that's free money free money to gamble
with let's get in on this action man NFL
season I'm loving this part of the year
so much good just everything to bet on
football basketball [ __ ] UFC uh NFL
baseball whatever now is the best time
to get your gamble on so go sign up for
a new account at mybookie use that promo
code bootleg and double your deposit
let's get back to the interview uh any
have you been binge watching any TV man
lately
lately nah not since the uh what's the
last [ __ ]
White Lotus like they got a new what you
call it coming out
uh season I think I'm excited for that
have you seen it why not HBO it's like
some comedy [ __ ] like this family goes
to some Island and it's like the mom dad
the daughter and the son the son's hella
young he's still like [ __ ] jacking
off every day on this phone to porn nice
the daughter is like damn is that like
[ __ ] dudes but brought a girl that
she's [ __ ] with too and it's just a
crazy [ __ ] so jack it off on your
phone every day is a young like child
thing to do is what you're saying so
you're saying I'm immature
I thought when she had your wife
gone
Jesus I think it's cheating if you buy
only fans content that's that's what
she's spending money on it if you're
spending money on it to me that's
you shouldn't be spending yeah that's
kind of crazy just get it for free on
Reddit I wouldn't know personally bet it
I wouldn't know personally that you can
get girls only fans I've never tried
that style so if you go on Reddit every
girls only fans is just ripped on there
for free I don't know that
from experience but I have a friend
whose entire livelihood is
you know pirating women's content on the
internet
it's a thing man
you watch a Curb Your Enthusiasm
uh no with Larry David it's on HBO
it's like the funniest show the old the
old white man you know it's like the
best Jewish father of all time yes I've
seen it a couple times and I've also
seen him at this golf course that I play
at you've seen him in person yes oh my
God see that's I tell my wife there's
two people I freak out about if I met
him
he's it's and they both look the same
if I met him or or Bernie Sanders I'd be
really excited Bernie huh
they're both kind of like they could
both kind of like passes each other you
know so don't let me meet Larry David
wow because I'm [ __ ] getting the
picture I don't give a [ __ ] if he hates
me I don't care I'm going through the
security I'm getting the [ __ ] selfie
I didn't get the picture Tom Brady was
also there that same day so I got the
picture with Tom Brady you passed up
Larry David for tone I know I know Kevin
Larry David might not be here much
longer that's true Tom Brady he's gonna
be single soon so you know he's going to
be raging with you at like 11 in Miami
soon enough
don't let Tom I would I hate like listen
Tom's in the middle of a divorce we
don't like to see anybody get divorced
but if he ends up going through with
this divorce he's going to be I think
Leonardo DiCaprio level of slang wow
like we're just gonna see him tied into
every
hot up and coming sucio boys let's go
for sure are you uh currently
relationship non-relationship
so you're uh you're you know Classic
Thai sucio boys
or olympio
I'm married are you a sushi or Olympia
I am not a sushio
all right I mean I'm a sick [ __ ] but I'm
not a I'm sick [ __ ] with my wife you
know it's all right you can still have a
wife and be a social I see I gotta make
sure we get those
we got to make sure that [ __ ] is clear
yeah yeah
shout out to Wifey man shout out to my
wife yeah shout out to the family that's
most important 100 man uh anything else
like a fan like for you like uh I feel
like you're somebody who I hear a lot of
people who are very much influenced by
you
do you feel like there's been anybody in
the last like 10 or 15 years like kind
of since you've been active that's also
had influence on you as well and your
sound or do you feel like you know
you're kind of
yeah I've been influenced by uh [ __ ]
from a long time ago say we talk about
Ella Fitzgerald like jazz era to I'm
talking about the new Prince to the new
[ __ ] for sure like there's been some
certain people that
hit different and you know my music
musical who are those people though uh
there's many
like a
I like uh
what's his name
the homie from Seattle McLemore uh nah
his name is uh
Highway oh I haven't heard him highway
is crazy uh what is it 2009 Highway 2009
check him out I like so fake so Faygo so
Faygo his Melodies and [ __ ] uh I like of
course blast blast is fine uh Brent
branches
[Music]
there's so many
were you kind of hip to blast because
he's like not a new artist in L.A he's
been doing something so the last uh I've
known him since King and bless when he
used to be in the group he's also my
homegirl lady G jizzles
relative and he's been around us since
the beginning since like a little kid
and uh to see him do it it's just been
like yes
that's exactly what was supposed to
happen and it's only I'm sure because he
kept on going yeah he's been at this for
a long time you know and uh that's what
it takes and he's mastered like every
aspect of the industry like he can
engineer himself he could do his own
artwork direct his own videos like kind
of like like if you really wanted to
like just lock in and handle your whole
process you could do that it's a lot of
work it is a lot of work but you're
capable of doing it I'm capable and I'm
capable of paying for it as well so you
know it's all good might as well pay
it's all good I got a lot on my plate
I got a lot that I'm doing yeah what
else besides uh the album are you
working on so TV [ __ ] here and there
some acting [ __ ] here and there I'm
getting into all type of [ __ ] you're
gonna see a whole bunch of [ __ ] just
start to drop over uh next year uh just
know I've been working hard I don't
really like to talk about a lot of stuff
until it's happening
but uh acting though yeah I like that
and uh just more music I got my record
label Easy Money Records I got my artist
Leon Thomas a few other artists and uh
we're about to go crazy Easy Money
Records Easy Money Records so that's new
because you had your other I had the
movement which I still have the movement
but I did a
Venture with Motown records with Easy
Money Records and uh
like I said Leon Thomas the first single
uh we had uh
we're on the second single right now
Love Jones so uh if you haven't heard it
make sure you go check it out and uh
it's one of the greatest as I said what
do you look for in an artist like design
uh it depends but with Leon it was like
wow like he played me as [ __ ] and and uh
he's making all the Beats he's singing
better than any of these singers I've
heard
um better than me [ __ ] he goes crazy and
it's just effortless like he's he just
bleeds that [ __ ] so shout out to Leon
man yo I'm gonna ask you something
because I
I feel like your voice is so special
thank you and I feel like it's so unique
and for people who don't know like you
really sing that way it's not like like
yeah obviously you have autotune on some
records when you're live you know to hit
those notes or whatever to make it sound
like the out the records but you don't
need that [ __ ] yeah right like do you
ever feel like
um
in terms of like your voice and you as a
singer do you feel like because you use
auto-tune and everyone's using auto-tune
right yeah but you like somehow like
your voice is still kind of like not
necessarily respected as much because I
think your voice is crazy like I've
heard you seeing live in the studio and
it just sounds like [ __ ] insane yeah
like everybody that appreciates the
singing part knows there's records
without the auto-tune and like when I do
use auto-tune that's just a sound I was
gonna say frequency just like if I
feature another artist on my song it's
the same thing it's me turning on the
auto-tune it's a frequency it's a sound
that I want it's the same thing it's me
choosing to use an acoustic guitar over
to an electric guitar instrument it's an
instrument it's a tool and like it
happens to be the sound that's in you
know so that's what I use on those type
of Records or if I switch up and make a
you know
an acoustic song I might I may not use
auto-tune or I may use it depending on
whatever I'm trying to do so
I'm one of the real ones when it comes
to the music [ __ ] for sure a hundred
percent how many instruments can you
play
every one of them if I really wanted to
play it the only thing that I haven't
like really dove into was uh Woodwinds
and Brass which is like horns saxophones
flutes to Trumpets okay woodwind is like
a flute Woodwinds is like the ones with
wood so like a sax got you got you got
you got you but I mean you can obviously
shred on the guitar and yeah it's hard
any type of string instrument I could
figure it out
anything with keys and any type of
percussion instrument you know what's
craziest recently I just found out that
Tame Impala is one guy yeah uh I had no
[ __ ] idea I knew I knew I knew and
then because I wasn't like ever a really
big fan until earlier this year
I went to Joshua Tree and I ate a [ __ ]
ton of mushrooms and
um I just found some playlists on
Spotify that was like mushroom music
yeah and this [ __ ] Tame Impala song
came on and that [ __ ] like changed my
life hey guys we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our good
folks over at bluetooth.com that's right
listen you gotta go to Bluetooth right
now sign up for uh Bluetooth with the
promo code bootleg you're gonna get your
first month for free Bluetooth the same
active ingredient as Viagra Ana Cialis
but in a chewable form that's right you
pop the blue Chew Chew that thing wash
it down with your beverage of choice and
then get to work with that hard [ __ ]
[ __ ] of yours your dick is going to be
harder than trigonometry was in high
school ladies and gentlemen it's gonna
be [ __ ]
like you know uh Ryu and Street Fighter
he'd be like and then he does the
[ __ ] this is gonna be your dick
it's gonna be like ryu's [ __ ]
uppercut you know what I'm saying God
bless you whoever's on the receiving end
of that consensually of course they're
going to thank you for taking the blue
shoe so go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg all right I'm talking
free month right to your doorstep in
discrete packaging no awkward doctors
visits all right it's all online you
don't have to worry about going and
sitting in a waiting room and be like
hey Doc uh my dick I could use a little
a pep in my step and then it's awkward
you gotta look at this old [ __ ] talking
about your dick he might ask you to pull
it out who [ __ ] knows what's going on
at Bluetooth none of that's happening
bluetooth.com and they also got the new
brand new
a mint flavored chewable which has
vardinophil in it which is the same
active ingredient as Levitra and staxin
which is a little more potent a little
more potent if you need the extra on top
of the extra you know what I mean get
the mint chewable yeah your wife will
thank you your girlfriend no thank you
your boyfriend will thank you whatever
the [ __ ] you're [ __ ] I'll thank you
as long as it's legal all right let's
get back to the interview go to
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg that's
it that was how it was when I found out
about the Unknown Mortal Orchestra you
ever heard about them nah so this is I
thought it was this other band from
Australia or New Zealand I heard this
[ __ ] one time on the other homie Anthony
Valadez show and I end up calling them
to the studio and I get to the studio
and it's one guy and he's doing all this
[ __ ] and it's kind of like a similar
Vibe so yeah I can appreciate real
musicians you know I'm saying they could
really just
put on a whatever a whole show one-man
band play everything everything put on a
program and go for that [ __ ] yeah so did
you discover that band while on
mushrooms as well or no not on mushrooms
I've done mushrooms a couple times but I
haven't really like in life you've only
done them a couple times yeah probably
like six or seven times in life oh but
uh I don't know why I just I just kind
of figured you're [ __ ] you're one of
them once no I don't I don't love it
that [ __ ] because I got a lot of work to
do so it's something called ego death so
I figured you know yeah but still like I
can't uh
just tap into mushrooms all the time
like I feel like it's been a wave of it
where like all the girls and all
everybody I'm doing mushrooms and [ __ ] I
couldn't I rather just smoke a j that's
fair have you ever done uh like any
other like DMT or anything I haven't
done DMT
I've done LSD I was like shrooms without
the little stomach feeling right it's
kind of similar the stomach feeling I'm
talking about oh I know yeah so it's the
same exact thing but without that dude I
was just saying before a longer time
three days ago off of a whole [ __ ]
bag of shrooms DJ Camilo's DJing my
[ __ ] brain is just bro I was in
[ __ ] so much bad money bunny getting
played and it sounds so much better I
was like Bad Bunny is the greatest
artist of all time
that's fine I want to see a show man I'm
hearing this tour it's been like the
best tour this year for sure I saw him
at a sofa and it was dope I I I was just
dope no it was great it was three hours
long so it was like I'm familiar with
like maybe 20 of his catalog but how was
the crowd though it was amazing my
favorite show I saw this year though was
the weekend and so far I said I wish I
would have got to catch that too yeah I
seen this last tour I think it was like
at the Staples Center a long ass time
ago right and that was like one of the
best tours I ever everything yeah I
think what was impressive about the
weekend was like um
how much he sounded just like the CD
live and he had like no like he didn't
have a lot of [ __ ] going on on stage and
it and he still captivated us are you
talking about the old songs
yeah I just mean like the CD no no so
like think about you know what I mean
[ __ ] dick
but like like the following night
because I saw him the first night and
the second night he stopped the show and
was like hey guys I mean you saw like he
was like I can't perform anymore and I'm
like that's that's dope because he's so
cognitively like aware of like how his
[ __ ] sounds that like if it doesn't
sound up to par yeah that's dope have
you done that before where you're like
my voice is just not compatible with the
show that's scheduled tonight it has to
happen in the middle of the show it's
happened before so and I just had to
cancel it so I know the feeling for sure
and
that's the right thing to do because at
the end of the day this is it's a money
maker it's your money maker is your tool
you know it's important so you got to
preserve that [ __ ] what's been the you
and uh even though I'm smoking yeah I
was about to say okay guys over here
chain smoking
um no I was gonna say uh you've had some
pretty uh you've been on some pretty
wild tours you've had some pretty crazy
moments of performed in some pretty
crazy places what has been like uh the
wildest night on tour with Ty Dolla Sign
I'm sure Jason Nacho's rolling up
backwards
um
well this night
maybe it's some backstage [ __ ] maybe
it's what happened after the show maybe
it's what happened at the show oh man
I can't call it there's so many wild
nights I'm trying to think of the
wildest
that I haven't talked about before
um
let me think of it and then let's go to
the next question and I'll interrupt
with the wildest night the wild stay
tuned for the wildest night stay tuned
Trey Sinatra I had Air Force Ones on
somewhere in the middle of America in
the middle of the tour bus in the
hallway with all of the lights off
pouring champagne on her oh that's great
uh yo um who who for you like um
you know you talk about uh obviously
raising your daughter man and I think
that there hasn't been enough artists
that like really own being a good dad
like you have you know whiz is one of
those guys we have friends who are who
are like that but I think in general
like there's
um a lack of that in terms of just like
what we see and I feel like
um you're a great dad and you're also a
rock star so how do you balance being a
rock star and being Thai who's also
sucio boy and also being a great father
uh
I feel like uh being a great father is
the most important if you ever get the
chance to be a father of put in that
position
um
that's just like common sense
people that don't do it I don't
understand them
who raised you [ __ ]
um
other than that uh being a socio boy and
a rock star and an artist that's my job
and it's the greatest job in the world
and I'm so happy to be able to make
funny make money and feed my family you
know through through that
if you weren't making music what would
your job have been man I can't imagine
it because this is just what I really
wanted to do but uh
and I feel like whatever you want to do
in life if you really want to do it as
long as you keep on doing it you can
turn it into whatever you know some
money
yeah but I don't know if that's true no
no
I mean there's some there's some rappers
out there that are that have been trying
for a long time I'm not saying anybody
of notoriety I mean like people I know I
know Phoenix Arizona you know like no I
know a lot of people that their music is
terrible okay well being terrible is one
thing well somebody got to tell you that
you know you gotta kick her see there's
different things you got to do first of
all you can go in there you can make a
song and you could think it's tight and
you can have like the dick riders
telling you it's tight but then you
gotta like ask around ask more people
it's all about they're all gonna lie to
you at the end of the day this is like a
people thing it's just like Ty just lied
to you you if you put your mind to it
not everybody can make money off of
music no that's a lot I'm not saying
everybody can make money off of music
but whatever you really want to do and
if it's not the music you got to figure
that out and see that it's not working
for you and do it in a different way
there's other avenues and music than you
being the artist yeah
that's now that's true yeah let's say
you're
obviously a garbage rapper maybe you
could be a well no you probably couldn't
be an a r because your Beats would at
least maybe you can manage somebody
maybe you can manage somebody maybe you
could um work at a record store yeah a
story yeah perfect you can maybe you
could be the security maybe you could be
a bodyguard yeah I mean yeah there's
actually cameraman you know
it's art to all of that though camera
yeah okay I feel like stuff like that is
very feasible because you can learn how
to edit video I don't know if you could
learn how to be like it could be the
sound man you can learn how to hook up
equipment in so many different ways
you could also I mean you probably can't
learn to be a security guard you got to
be like a certain
like
body type but you're you know what your
security guard uh well one of your guys
I forget I forget your boy's name the
Armenian guy who's I don't know if he's
still around with you but uh he uh he's
also he's a badass [ __ ] but also
not like a typical looking security guy
so I guess you can't judge a book by its
cover yeah for sure because some of
these security dudes are they pack
they're tiny but they're [ __ ] they
know like they're like [ __ ] Green
Berets or some [ __ ] you know yeah
hey we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our partners at
Odd Socks our presenting sponsor here at
the bootleg hit podcast listen Christmas
time is approaching faster than you
think I mean we're like [ __ ] a month
and a half away or some [ __ ] whatever uh
get some Odd Socks for your folks go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and you'll save 20 off at
checkout the most comfortable socks in
the world that's right
we got some Scarface socks they got WWE
yeah I mean they also got the Cheech and
chongs they also got the Flamin Hots for
you hot Cheeto eating [ __ ] out there my
favorite just the odd Sox Basics they're
just so comfy literally the most
comfortable sock in the world I'm
holding the [ __ ] sock right now you
can save 20 off plus they got boxers now
baby all right go to Odd Socks
official.com promo code bootleg at
checkout save 20 off and support our
family at odd Sox and the podcast at the
same [ __ ] time let's get back to the
interview you playing any video games
right as of now off and on um Call of
Duty or Call of Duty Pub G pubg huh yeah
I still love pubg uh NBA 2K Madden
first of all the new man is God awful
but it's awful that's terrible okay I
didn't even happen yet uh who's your
team on 2K though I mean the Lakers
do you feel like conflicted that Russell
Westbrook is a great guy and he's from
LA but he's also the reason why the
Lakers are a [ __ ] dumpster fire right
now you're gonna just say he's the sole
reason why they're dumb surprised I
would say he's 60 to 70 of the reason
why I feel like if they just told him to
go home
and just not play they would just get
it's like addition by subtraction did
you see the other night when he pulled
up with like 30 seconds left
and he and and everybody was like no no
[Laughter]
come on bro
who's the reason give me okay let's why
do the Lakers suck
you think it's a d over Westbrook
this guy's from New York don't listen to
this [ __ ] guy's a Knicks fan maybe he
should be the leader though that that
does make sense
who A.D LeBron's the leader
he's in declining average 30 points a
game last year what are you talking
about
let's not listen to him he's like
[ __ ] rooting for Julius Randle and
[ __ ] Jalen Brunson over there yeah
Jesus Christ nah uh
shout out to Russia shout out to Russ
man I think people just got to realize
what you know their talent and when it
works and when it doesn't it stops
you know I'm guessing I think you gotta
have self-awareness to like openly
accept other roles yes so like if you're
self-aware enough to be like
but I don't think he's hit that yet yeah
like Melo kind of had to hit that and
then he came back and was like
productive for the Blazers and
I don't know if he's playing right now
but yeah shout out to Russ yeah
legendary guy
um La has been in a really like
interesting place since the pandemic in
terms of just like
it's always been I mean everywhere is
dangerous right but perceptually a lot
of stuff has happened in La that is kind
of giving La a bad rep in terms of just
like you know obviously rest in peace to
p b rock people have gotten killed here
people got murdered here
robbed all that are you with the current
climate of the city do you move move
around a little bit differently man and
the one why do you think it is
currently like uh I think it's just more
publicly uh on display right now
it's always been some [ __ ] I'm from La
so there's always been some [ __ ] of
course like happening
[Music]
um
move different now we always moves I
feel like the right way
I've been in
certain [ __ ] where maybe I was too
comfortable before and had to get awoken
you know what I'm saying but uh
everybody move safe you know and that's
anywhere
especially since the pandemic though
yeah I feel like people are more a
little bit more hungry and [ __ ]
uh like right coming out of it like when
you started seeing how people just get
robbed just in broad daylight yeah I
think like I've had laws that
made it okay made it okay and you had
masks that made it like easier and yeah
like you could walk around with the push
iced tea on and no one right so
everybody uh you know be careful and
stay dangerous did you have a
relationship with PB yes uh shout out to
pnb man and his family he was a very
cool dude from all the times we
um encountered each other yeah and uh
it's super sad and
super light down like really
right and you know what's crazy about
him like he was such a nice guy and then
when you hear like the circumstances of
what happened and it was like a family
like a father and a son thing you're
like [ __ ] dude like
it's just crazy man it's a sad situation
for sure man it is you know like you
said stay safe out here
um album by the end of the year
uh we got the biggest single in the
[ __ ] world right now my friends
anything album related he's just the
first of the single okay you got the
single out the album comes out January
then you know the album is coming soon
let's focus on the biggest song right
now my friends featuring a little dirt
shout out to my brother mustard we out
here and then uh any more collab
projects coming obviously you have some
Classics you got the division album you
got the Jeremiah project you got [ __ ]
you and Wiz I mean
yeah uh I love doing music and I love
making music with other people that love
making music and I've got some great
[ __ ] on the way with him how about this
I'm not gonna ask you because you're
just gonna tell me about the single uh
if you who would be somebody that you
are a fan of that you would like to do a
project with if you if you could have it
your way
I like what Drake like
you and Drake that would be hard yeah
you and Drake would be crazy
um I don't know who else
uh me and Kaylani would make a crazy
album together for sure that'd be easy
you guys are both on Atlantic yeah
that'd be crazy
keilani we got to talk to David Ali
let's make it happen yes sir she's been
killing it too shout out to her man well
I appreciate you pulling up you didn't
answer the question about your craziest
night on tour you didn't think about it
see I'll send it in on a video or
something I don't want to see the video
you shouldn't be sharing that video I
don't want to see that video
my girl there was 11 winning boys in the
building
Ty Dollar Sign boom let's get it fire